we would love to do a rapid fire get
into many of our favorite
movies that you were in and if you could
share any fun facts about them we would
be so delighted
in something we call behind the scenes
um okay here's how it works we're gonna
show you a movie that you were in and we
would love for you to share a detail
an insider a fly on the wall moment
anything that comes to mind first up
saint almost fire um
well it was offset what comes to me
first is i was
renting uh a place out in los angeles
and my next-door neighbor was um
betty davis and i never saw her and so
one night i
had a few drinks and i decided i'm gonna
go meet betty davis
and i went and i i knocked on a door
and then i panicked and i just ran home
so i sort of
and that was it i never met her um okay
um mannequin the first thing always
comes to my mind about mannequin is
that i hated that motor i'd ride a
motorcycle in the movie and i couldn't
ride it i would just get so tense when i
do it like my shoulders would tense up
so much that i crashed
early on and they realized that no he's
not joking he can't ride the motorcycle
and so they had to just
hook it up with some rig every time i
wrote it and so that i would be pulled
along and have to they put a fan on me
to blow my hair
and all this kind of stuff because i was
so incapable of riding my motorcycle
um okay less than zero
i never read the book my big secret from
lesson zero is i never read it
um which we would all sit around and
they would talk about the book and i
would be like yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i'm like i have no idea
what they're talking about
but it was kind of good because the
movie had nothing to do with the book i
don't think it was a single line from
the book in the movie
but i did end up reading it decades
later
but uh yeah i wasn't much of a reader
back then
okay last one weekend at bernie's
see the problem with telling stories
about bernie is everything is on screen
anything you could think of it wasn't
stupid enough
i remember it's like what's staple let's
say he has a two-pane staple his hair on
him like okay put a ball cap on him with
staple his head
you know there's a scene when we're
doing monopoly playing monopoly
uh i was playing it up against ted
bernie and it wasn't in the script i
just had nothing to do and i had been
playing monopoly at home the night
before so i brought my monopoly set to
work and i said let me play bernie and
monopoly so we just had this monopoly
match and
it turned out to be great you know you
could do anything to bernie you could
just drag him around we realized the
more you abuse his body
the funnier it's going to be there is a
folklore if you will
that my grandfather john barrymore they
took his body out of the morgue his
friends wc
field satakichi hartman john decker
and gene fowler and they partied with
him and it's this
infamous story and they say
i have heard rumors that it was like a
molecule of inspiration for weekend at
bernie's did you ever hear that
that could well have been true but we
did not have such a fine pedigree as
that we were just
running around with this dead body so as
fabulous
as they all were they were total
hedonists and party animals and
they were totally a bunch of hooligans
by the way really quickly i didn't know
this
is it true that you wore a wig at the
very end of pretty in pink because you
had shaved your head for less than zero
already
no i i was doing a play in new york and
i shaved my head and uh but i do have a
wig on at the end of pretty pigmented
because we've re-shot the ending and so
when i go to molly at the prom and tell
her that i love her and i'm a terrible
person and she's
great um that was all of research they
never die in these movies
they and they can't uh they're such a
part of our history
andrew mccarthy brat and 80's story is
out now everywhere books are sold thank
you andrew